[inaudible].
Yeah.
Sending this one out to my evolutionary
psychology people.
Yeah.
David bus.
Cosmic in Tubey.
Yeah.
Jeffrey Miller.
We live in this till the day that we
die.
Survival or the feet only the strong
survive.
There's walk and went on outside.
No Man is safe.
You can run but you can't have ever,
you come to my black,
you'll see some territoriality.
You please wear a kill or be killed is
the mentality would get his street.
It's just a necessary strategy.
You got to play the hand.
You're dealt.
What can magic?
We escaped from the habitat that she was
born in three homicides and when
neighborhood is cops came and kicked the
crooked door with no warning.
I started roughing up my young cousins.
She's only 17 and counterpoint in the
oven plus a concussion,
but she ain't done nothing.
So keep your mouth shut.
Don't jump to judgment on the lads were
living.
Just close your eyes and listen with
that.
Pre counsel.
Homicide statistics.
So if you think the criminal man,
it's just bacon,
you're mistaken.
This is calculated risk taking.
We did banana situation with the low
life expectancy and a major discrepancy
between the haves and the have nots.
And You wonder why the padlock on every
cashbox smashed off.
Come on.
You can't call a pathological.
Nah,
that's a logical,
you can try to understand it,
but you can't stop a doe.
Not Unless you address the root causes
is the conscious and unconscious
decisions to discount future prospects.
C'Mon,
it's obvious the beekeeper bouncing
homicide rate keeps mounting,
which leaves this deep discounting and a
lot of violence,
but it's not.
A virus is a rational response to high
risk environments and short time
horizons with high stakes and highly
visible prizes and you wonder why we're
criminal minded.
Hey,
you can't say we'll get satisfaction and
for patient with self control and delete
gratification when the only job that
pays his casket baking death is the
ultimate plan cancellation to check the
facts and recent data release.
It shows a pattern of increasing
competition,
a bunch of young guys off struggling
status seeking,
causing the crabs and make the social
fabric weekend and life expectancy also
predicts teen pregnancy.
The need to leave a legacy genetically
will never be completely control
contraceptive.
The,
yeah,
the transparent.
Imagine if your kids would never meet
the grandparents unless they followed
the Bristol Pailin Plan for parenthood
and then they see these young girls were
fall down.
Carolyn's do get pregnant before
marriage is such a tragedy.
Apparently.
It's also a reproductive strategy,
especially when you could see them
adjusting activity when their
circumstances change.
In both the cases of the young ladies
with babies in the mail risk takers,
you see people that depth into their
situation and it's the same in different
places and with different reasons.
This is not about ethical justification.
It's evolutionary psych in,
it's just the basics.
I'm still,
people call this behavior maladaptive
because of our reaction when violence
happens,
but if we really want to change the
outcome,
then maybe we should just start
questioning how it's it.
And the bottom line is that a nick woody
and life expectancy or the ultimate
causes of crime and the results of
crime,
to me that's true that you could bind
together in a feedback loop,
but it got some moves to make now.
So I'll be back soon.
Just don't ask me what I'm about to do,
right.
Because I can't see,
so what's left the on tour effect,
but you're my death and my goal is to
stay alive.
Survival of the fee.
Only the strong survive.
That's right.
We live in this till the day that we
die.
It's the Bible.
Only the strong survive been this till
the tea that we die survivals are the
fee only the strong survive.
That's right.
We live in this till the tape that we
die.
It's the Bible of the fee.
Only the strong survive this till the
day that we die.
Survival of the fee.
Only the strong survive.
That's right.
We live in this till the tea that we dad
survival over the fit.
Only the strong.
Strong,
strong.
Yeah.
Sending this out on the evolutionary
psychologists,
Daly and Wilson.
Steven pinker.
Robert Reich.
Yeah.
David Sloan.
Wilson.
Yeah,
that's right.
Gathered the evidence.
Make it real.
Make it real human mentality and you
represent,
yes.
Human Nature.
Human Nature to the core mine and you
get Joe's don't question my actions
unless you're ready to make a little
addition and before I make a subtraction
up and traction.
That's right.
Love scrapping
please.
I'm here talking today with Dr. Martin
Daly.
Doctor daily is a professor of
psychology at mcmaster university in
Hamilton,
Ontario and author of many influential
papers on evolutionary psychology.
His current research topics include an
evolutionary perspective on risk taking
and interpersonal violence,
especially male male conflict
and fast.
He and his wife that late Margo Wilson
where the former editors in chief of the
journal evolution and human behavior and
former presidents of the human behavior
and evolution society.
He was named a fellow of the Royal
Society Canada in 1998 daily is one of
the main researchers of the Cinderella
effect and has been interviewed many
times in the press about it.
So I'm very pleased to be talking with
doctor daily this morning.
It seems to me that he's one of Canada's
most outstanding psychologists and
perhaps you could say that about
psychologists in the world.
And he's done some incredibly
interesting research on the relationship
between inequality and male violence and
inequality and other topics too.
So welcome Dr Daily.
Thank you Jordan.
It's nice to be talking to you.
Well,
I'm looking forward to our conversation
a lot.
So you just wrote a book,
which I'm going to show people called
killing the competition
and uh,
I just read it.
It was very interesting.
So I thought maybe I could get you to
start by talking a little bit about the
book and,
and also how you tell us,
tell us the story that would be the,
the good,
a good thing to do.
Well,
the general issue that is addressed in
the book is the relationship between
economic and inequality,
which is usually indexed as income
inequality and homicide rates.
And it's been known for a long time by
sociologists that income inequality is
the single best predictor they've got of
homicide rates across countries,
across states,
within the u s across cities within the
u s and some other kinds of
jurisdictional comparisons and there has
been controversy about why that is and
whether any quality itself is truly the
problem or whether it's just a correlate
of something else.
And in this book I tried to make the
case that no inequality really is the
problem and some of the arguments that
have been events for suggesting that
Amir correlate of violence rather than
in some way causal to violence are
wrong.
Can you tell us a little bit about how
you calculate inequality and what the
measure is?
Yeah,
income inequality.
There's a number of different measures
that are used by economists and I'm just
borrowing the dominant ones from
economists.
The number one one is something called
the Gini Index Gin.
I,
I used to assume that that was some kind
of a acronym,
but actually it was the name of an
Italian economist and it's a measured
that is rages from zero to one.
It would be zero if everybody had
exactly the same income or exactly the
same wealth if you're doing wealth
inequality and it would approach one as
income or wealth was concentrated more
and more in the hands of few and then a
single individual and in principle would
go to one in the extreme if all wealth
were held by Bill Gates and done in the
rest of us had anything.
Now you analyze the,
the judy coefficient to have different
levels of of jurisdiction.
Hey,
so I noticed in your work that you've
looked at countries and states within
countries and I think that's
particularly true in the u s so tell us
a little bit about what you found.
Yeah.
Well with within the U S and again this
has been done by sociologists for some
time within the u s and cross
nationally.
Um,
the Gini Coefficient is a very good
predictor of homicide.
The correlation tends to be on the order
of 0.7 in many studies,
which means that the variants in either
measure 50% of it could be a count of
four by no variability.
And the other measure when I'm saying
between homicide and income and
equality,
and actually it even works on a
neighborhood level.
My late wife Margaux and I publish some
analyses in Chicago that showed they
didn't cut any quality,
wasn't very strong predictor of homicide
rates across neighborhoods within
Chicago.
Tell us a little bit about
you did in Chicago cause that that
research is extremely interesting and
also when you did it.
Um,
let's see.
We did our work in Chicago in the early
nineties and at that time Chicago had a
very high homicide rate,
not the worst in the United States,
but one of the worst in the United
States and in fact have more homicides
every year.
And then the whole of Canada,
which makes it a substantial enough
phenomenon that you can sort of look for
causal factors or correlates without a
lot of stochastic noise.
Um,
it,
Chicago,
Chicago is divided up into some 77 I
believe,
neighborhoods by,
there's a longstanding tradition of
urban sociology in Chicago and there's
these sort of well recognized 77
neighborhoods in any way for these
neighborhoods.
We were able to amass a variety of
neighborhoods,
specific information including an income
distributions on homicides and so forth.
Uh,
working with the Chicago police who were
collaborators in some of this work and
Margo,
um,
went to the Illinois Department of
Health to try and get information on
other death rates and birth rates and
demographic structure of each of the
neighborhoods.
And she wanted to compute the life
expectancy because the idea that she had
was the local life expectancy.
Would he affect the extent to which
people were willing to sort of escalate
dangerously in competitive situations in
competitive.
And that was our construal of what most
homicides in Chicago.
We're about where guys killing each
other when dissed embars,
um,
circumstances in which there is some
sort of competition and it gets
dangerous and are our basic idea.
They are.
And elsewhere has been that a lot of the
variability in homicide rates,
the most violent,
volatile component of homicide rates has
to do with this male male competition.
And where,
where I'm,
when does it get dangerous and where or
when does it sort of dampen down.
And for Chicago Anyway,
the Illinois Department of Health had
never,
nobody had ever computed neighborhoods
specific life expectancy,
but the data were available to do it,
age specific [inaudible] and sell.
I was available to do it.
And so we computed a significant life
expectancies,
income equality and many other variables
that uh,
criminologists have considered relevant
in past studies,
racial heterogeneity and blah,
blah,
blah and tried to see what were your
best predictor.
So homicide and in that particular
study,
everywhere else we've worked,
we've mostly found incoming equality
would be number one in that particular
study,
incoming equality was a very good
predictor,
but the best predictor was male life
expectancy at age,
at birth or an age 15.
And in order to compute,
like of course you say homicide rates,
homicide reduces male life expectancy.
So you have to remove homicides
statistically as a cause of death and
say life expectancy net of the impact of
homicide,
that was our best predictor of homicide
rates.
And life expectancy is very variable in
the city of Chicago.
And I assume that other US cities,
I mean the worst neighborhoods,
male life expectancy at birth was down
in the 50s as bad as in the worst
countries in the world,
in the best neighborhoods,
male life expectancy was up in the I
think was over 80 or in the high
seventies in any case,
um,
corresponding to what you might expect
in Scandinavia are the places but the
best life expectancy in the world.
So it was a huge range.
That was our best predictor than if you
try and do a multivariate analysis where
you look for,
well,
what else predicts some the residual
variability and there wasn't much
research tool variability.
The second best indeed,
the only secondary predictor that seemed
to be statistically significant was
income inequality across the
neighborhoods.
That was,
that was the thrust of our,
our study in Chicago.
And I got lots to see more work on life
expectancy as a predictor of violence,
um,
of a university.
Take them all right.
Y'All crib it all.
And just mark,
we've tried to do the same thing in
Montreal,
but he felt that a Montreal,
the difference in life expectancy for
men between the worst and the best
neighborhoods was only six years,
whereas Chicago,
it was 24 years,
I think.
So what do you,
what do you think accounted for the vast
difference in life expectancy between
Chicago and Montreal?
Was life expectancy itself associated
with income inequality?
Well,
yes.
I mean that's part of the problem of
course in all this kind of research
here,
it's not experimental research.
You don't control independent variables
and everything of potential interest is
correlated with everything else.
So,
you know,
income inequality alone accounts for
more than half the variance in homicide
rates across Chicago neighborhoods.
So does life expectancy alone.
Um,
so does percent below the poverty line
alone.
Um,
you know,
like these things are all correlated
with each other.
And so try to tease apart what's most
important is tricky.
So the low life expectancy,
Chicago neighborhoods is not due to
violence.
A student,
it's,
it's too overwhelming lead to
differential disease.
Um,
in Chicago,
you know,
privatization of medicine in the U s was
so extremely tight.
We were doing this research.
Emergency rooms in the worst
neighborhoods in Chicago had closed down
because they got bankrupt.
Um,
they didn't have enough money to remain
open and therefore if you got stabbed or
shot in a bad neighborhood in Chicago,
you had to be transported somewhere else
to try and keep you alive because there
was,
you know,
the hospitals and shut their emergency
rooms or had shut down completely.
So there's all sorts of factors that
contribute to a,
to differential death rates.
But you know,
kids in the worst neighborhood are
exposed to high levels of wed.
There's some evidence that lead exposure
and childhoods is a big predictor of
variability of life expectancy.
Um,
all kinds of internal diseases.
They were more susceptible to the
effects of bad nutrition.
They were more susceptible to.
So if you divide causes of death and
just so called external causes,
which basically means homicides,
suicides and accidents and internal
causes,
which is more or less synonymous with
what we ordinarily think of as disease
internal causes,
we're still the biggest source of
differential mortality across
neighborhoods.
So you could make by the sounds of it,
you could make a reasonable case that
the same social safety net in Canada is
flattening out the bottom of the,
of the income distribution,
especially the provision of healthcare.
And you know,
I also
was informed a while back,
uh,
that the rate of entrepreneurship in
Canada is actually higher than in than
in the u s and part of the reason for
that is that because healthcare is
provided,
people can take a risk of walking away
from their jobs without putting their
family completely at risk.
And so one of the perverse effects of
socialized medicine is that it elevates
the rates of entrepreneurship.
So I also wanted to mention,
you know,
your,
your work was absolutely striking to me
because of the effect sizes.
Now for people who don't know about,
uh,
how to compare effects sizes,
I should point out that you never see a
correlation of 0.7 between any two
variables in the social sciences.
So there's a guy named Hamp Hale who did
an empirical analysis of effect size
comparisons,
uh,
about four or five years ago.
Might be longer than that now.
And he concluded that 95% of social
science studies had a effect size of 0.5
or less.
And so to see a correlation of 0.7 is
absolutely overwhelming when you also
take into account that measurement error
is decreasing the potency of the
relationship to some degree.
So that's,
and when you take into account that,
uh,
that those,
that 0.5 represents studies that were
published because they got something.
Yes,
exactly.
Exactly.
So,
so 0.7 it's absolutely overwhelming.
I've never seen effect sizes that big
between two variables of interest in any
other domain that I can recall.
And then the other thing that's worth
pointing out,
and we can talk about this a little bit
too,
is the other thing that's so radical
about your research is that it,
and,
and this,
this what emerges out of the,
out of the manner in which the Gini
Coefficient is,
is calculated because it's only a
measure of relative poverty.
Um,
and it's the predictor.
You,
you also generate it data indicating
that places where everyone was
relatively poor or say relatively
working class like North Dakota and some
of the Canadian provinces had very low
homicide rates and also places where
everyone was rich.
Right?
So to rate reiterate,
what you're seeing is that what's
driving male homicide is the existence.
And for,
you know,
correct me if I'm wrong,
the existence of a steep economic
dominance hierarchy that makes it
difficult for the young men to obtain
status through what you might describe
as conventional and socially productive
means.
And so instead they turned to violence
as a means of establishing status.
And most of that's within race and
between young men jockeying for
position.
Is that all correct?
Yeah,
I,
I think that's a pretty fair
characterization.
Um,
uh,
it's,
it's worth stressing.
Yes.
That income inequality is in principle
and in practice dissociable from just
averaging cub or 4% below the poverty
line or other measures of cell called
absolute a deprivation,
they're often correlated,
you know,
income inequality across a certain set
of jurisdictions,
maybe fairly strongly correlated with,
um,
the percent below the poverty line.
For example.
It'd be surprising if it was not,
you should correlated,
but,
uh,
but they're not necessarily as you said.
Yeah.
So you demonstrate it or you were one of
the first people to demonstrate where
you,
the first,
in fact maybe that it wasn't poverty
that was causing this kind of crime.
It was relative poverty and that that
changes the interpretation of the
situation.
Absolutely.
Dramatically.
So tell us a little bit about why you
think that males are competing in this
deadly manner.
What's driving that behavior?
Well,
it's very interesting,
I think.
I think men are sensitive to or
interested in relative position status
of maintaining face in competitive
billions.
And in a sense,
all videos are a bit competitive.
Um,
and the willingness to use bio,
it's partly s can be thought of as kind
of a disdain for the future or I walked
by now,
um,
I'm willing to do something that
threatens by wife,
like escalate and competition are not
backed out or not walk away from an
insult because I'm thinking very short
term the rewards for,
for being passive.
You know,
if you're,
if you're a nice of Prosperous
University,
student of age 20,
you have good life prospects,
your chances for eventually becoming a
well paid,
uh,
maybe people will laugh at this are
still reasonably good.
Your chances for eventually burying are
still reasonably good if you're the same
age guide to guy,
um,
in,
uh,
urban ghetto with a 48% of the
appointment,
right?
Or something like that,
that you have very much more Ed ed with
uncertainty about the stability of
whatever income you do get with,
with,
um,
the future of node,
then you're more willing to take a risk
now in the pursuit of status now and the
produce suit of sexual opportunity now
in the pursuit of monetary rewards,
illegal or illicit now.
And also the maintenance of face,
like social reputation is the one
resource you've got.
If you've got other resources you could
walk away from threats or or
disrespect,
um,
add and reap your rewards later.
If social status is all you've got,
then it becomes an important thing to
defend.
So I read some research a while back.
It looked at the relationship between
socioeconomic status among men and
number of sexual partners and also
socioeconomic status among women,
a number of sexual partners.
And that's another domain where you see
these kinds of whopping correlations.
So the correlation between socioeconomic
status for men and number of available
sexual partners is about 0.6 or 0.7.
Whereas for women it's negative 0.12 and
so do you think,
so do you think that it's reasonable to
assume that either at the phylogenetic
level level or the on a genetic level
leave either evolutionarily speaking or
even as a consequence of rational
calculation that part of the reason that
men are perhaps the main reason that men
are engaging in these status
competitions is because of female hyper
gummy?
Is that a reasonable,
is that a reasonable hypothesis?
Hypercarbia and as you say,
set up simple access.
I mean there,
there is
there,
the association that you mentioned is
presumably a very longstanding one.
That is to say that bed ups with status
et resources have had access to partners
for sure.
And probably multiple partners
simultaneously or serially.
Um,
to a degree that bed of lower status
have dot.
There's high variates it eventual
reproduction among males in mammals
generally.
And although the situation is less
extreme and people that have been the
other battles,
the same is true for people.
I mean what you say,
they have high variates compared to
what?
Well,
high variates compared to women for
example,
of the variability and eventual
reproductive success as well.
Where for women than for men or husband.
Now you say sexual to it,
but I think that's exactly the right
level to be working out got in
contemporary societies.
But the reason why that matters is
because ancestrally that translated into
differential reproduction in a moderate
environment of which you don't cut.
Perceptive technology is available,
especially to women than,
uh,
that that correlation may be broken
down.
But the motives to seek sexual
opportunity,
um,
remain relevant.
So one of the things that I wanted to
talk to you about too,
is to,
like you,
you,
you made a comment in your book about
Adrian Rates and Adrian rains has
written a book recently about the
biological predictors of criminality.
And you make a strong case that in some
sense the,
the,
the turning to violence that's
characteristic of men in uncertain
situations is rational because it
drives,
it actually legitimately drive status
increase and that produces a variety of
positive effects.
So in some sense it's a rational
response to a radically uncertain
environment where competition is high.
Now reigns would say no biological type
researchers they look at,
they look more at the individual level
and conclude that it's individuals who
have various forms of prefrontal damage
or,
or characterological issues associated
with antisocial personality disorder
that are more likely to engage in
violent acts.
And you can track that.
I mean,
Rashard Trombley has done some of this
work in Quebec.
You can track the emergence of
aggression at an individual level all
the way back to children at two years of
age because it turns out that children
who are two are the most violent
children,
particularly the boys,
but mostly a subset of boys who who
can't fight,
hit and bite and steel at two,
most of whom are socialized by the age
of four,
but a subset of whom are not socialized
and then they become,
they're more likely to become the
lifetime offenders.
And,
and so what I'm wondering is maybe you
can reconcile the difference between the
two research streams like this.
Imagine that as the economic gradient
increases and the dominance hierarchy
becomes steeper and steeper,
the men who are prone to be violent,
I'm like,
it's the disagreeable men that start to
be violet first,
maybe ones that have an impulse control
problem or that are character a
logically like,
like the violent two year olds that are
character logically predisposed to be
violent.
It seems to me that those would be the
ones that,
you know,
as the pressure increases,
those men who are more prone to violence
for other reasons are going to be the
people who react with violence first.
You think that's a reasonable
hypothesis?
Yeah,
I think that's a very reasonable
hypothesis.
I mean,
my objection to atria raids book was
that I think he vast,
you know,
he's,
there's definitely evidence that betty
kinds of,
uh,
violet criminal offenders have got
something wrong with their braids.
Eight Rehab Ray bloods to extrapolate to
the conclusion that violent criminals I
did.
Deep criminals in general have got
something broken about their braids and
it's like criminality is pathological.
Well,
criminality is not pathological.
People steal for cost benefit related
reasons.
Um,
the crime is a,
if you like God help us social
construction in the sense that,
um,
certain behaviors are criminalized by a
larger social group.
It ordered to the turn up because self
interested individuals but otherwise
pursued them.
You know,
how do you make people stop exploiting
others,
stealing from others
by criminalizing those activities and
imposing penalties.
And you know there's a rational choice
of stream of theorizing within
criminology that that other people like
Adrian Ray just dismiss out of head.
No,
no.
Criminal offenses are pathological.
Yeah and I think that's silly.
Well it seems unnecessary
because it is also difficult to make a
marriage between the two issues.
Like one of the best predictors,
you know I do research on individual
differences in personality and the best
personality predictor of incarceration
is low agreeableness.
That's one of the dimensions on which
men and women differ the most.
And so as you become more disagreeable,
you become more self oriented I would
say.
And that can push past the point where
you're so self interested that you're
willing to prey on others.
And so those are the guys that as well
as the guys who lack impulse control,
those are the guys,
the first guys to turn to violence,
let's say when the socioeconomic
conditions become sufficiently unstable
so that a conscientious approach is not
tenable.
Yeah,
that's at the marriage between that kind
of thing.
Keg Ed ed thinking about irrelevant so
that any quality is that there's guys at
the top who are white,
the violet people you described,
there's people doing very well who are
very happy to explain to others,
but the costs of individual bio it
action are high enough and the
opportunities to exploit other people
through sight.
And she'll be just through your lawyers,
um,
through whatever tactics are available
to,
you know,
well he'll bullies are,
are safe enough that they opt to behave
with those directions,
right?
Because they've gone to their longterm
future is relatively stable.
And so that longterm planning and
regulation of behavior actually play an
important economic role.
Add,
add,
you know,
and then in the case of somebody like
Donald Trump,
I mean,
he looks like somebody who's suffering a
little bit of an impulse control
problem,
especially sort of during the night when
he wakes up and does his twitter account
is too close at head.
But he's,
he's rich enough to bully people at
other ways that actually heads on
violence.
Although come to think of it,
uh,
the famous remark that he made during
the campaign about women suggests
perhaps that,
you know,
it depends on your definition of heads
on violence,
I guess that qualifies.
Okay.
So,
um,
there's a very large body of research
that indicates that alcohol is a major
contributor to criminality too,
especially with regards to men.
Um,
and so both 50% of people who were
murdered have a decent blood alcohol
level and about 50% of murders.
And I think that's partly that stat is
equal equalizes,
I think because much violence among men
is exactly the sort that you described
where it's a status dispute and it's
more or less a toss up who's going to
come out as a winner.
But then I guess what's happening with
alcohol perhaps is that because it's a
disinhibitor because it reduces anxiety
and anxiety is one of the suppressors of
aggressive behavior that men who are
already on the edge,
let's say,
because of the unstable environment and
the steep dominance arc,
you're also more likely lose control
when they're drinking.
And maybe that's also fuel.
This is something to that I'm curious
about.
I mean,
you can think about it as a rational
calculation,
but,
but I'm also curious about the degree to
which it's fueled by emergent negative
emotions.
So it's easy for people who are in a
steep dominance hierarchies to regard
this system as unfair and to become
resentful and angry about it as perhaps
they should be.
I'm not suggesting that that's
necessarily an irrational response,
but it seems that if the anger is
simmering underneath the surface,
that it's waiting in some sense for an
opportunity to break free and alcohol in
a bar or at home perhaps provides that,
that that route.
What you say makes evidence says to be,
I made a boat,
it's probably worth injecting a bit of a
caution about the word rationality
generally well,
but talks about,
um,
rationality and cry,
but perhaps especially a confrontational
violence.
The point is not that the person has
making good and carefully weigh
decisions.
I mean,
I think,
you know,
emotions are the handmaid of what I
would call ecological rationality.
They,
they help you know how you should feel
about certain things and how you should
react to them.
And the rationality clay as more on clay
above this person gets riled up,
resents x ad there.
Eddie should it.
There's good reason to get routed up at
breeze at x.
But the fact that alcohol,
perhaps this inhibits so that you know,
the,
the truly rational ballots between
inhibitory and aggressive emotions is
altered.
The idea that ration that alcohol
interferes with,
with cognitive process,
which is the point that people are start
making stupid decisions when they're
drunk,
uh,
decide to get behind the wheel or
whatever.
I think this plays very heavily yet to
the reason why.
So Betty Hobbyist sides tend to happen
in contexts like two drunks is
assaulting each other and stuff or you
know,
people who are somewhat under the
influence of alcohol and insulting each
other rather than uh,
you know,
with you,
if you have more,
if you have more bed til wherewithal at
the moment,
you probably have better capacities to
confuse date to diffuse dangerous
situations through,
um,
you know,
ways that don't tail losing face by,
by being articulate.
Great.
Exactly.
That's right.
You have other tools at your disposal
rather than immediate recourse to your
fists.
Thank you.
Yes.
So if I remember correctly,
two and your Chicago Studies,
this is one of the things that I found
particularly fascinating was you tracked
the consequences of killing someone in
Chicago and the consequences were
something of the following sort.
Well,
first of all,
you are likely to be charged with
something like second degree murder.
It would be difficult for the police to
find people to testify against you.
And if they did,
generally what they would say is that it
was a two way altercation.
And so in many cases you could plead
self defense.
Often it didn't go before a jury because
the perpetrator plea bargain to down to
manslaughter.
The sentence was something on the,
on the order of a couple of years and
people were generally out of prison in
18 months with a substantial boost in
their social capital because now they
were like dangerous sons of bitches not
to be messed with.
And that was quite clear and also
perhaps also improved so to speak by
their soldier and in prison is that is
if I got that right,
except for what detail?
Well,
actually it,
our Chicago studies,
we didn't have as good followup
information is what you're talking
about.
This,
this was a early,
a piece of research in the city of
Detroit that uh,
that led to most of those findings.
But uh,
but yeah,
exactly.
Um,
hardly,
it's interesting.
We had a,
we had a single year sample of cases of
Detroit and there were I think 590
homicide to Detroit that one year night,
he'd 72 at which time Detroit did have
the highest homicide rate.
The U s s a large majority of these are
bail bail dispute.
So some sort of status disputes usually,
but sometimes robberies and just as you
said,
um,
witnesses are unlikely to come forward
and have the prosecutors are stretched.
They don't have,
they don't have the resources that they
would need to pursue every case.
And so they,
many cases were dismissed.
I'd be not even prosecuted,
never buy play bark and something like
approximately half of all male male
macho dispute homicides in Detroit that
were solved.
We're not prosecuted.
And the expectation that there was a
self defense argument that bites,
you know,
with,
with the jury that of the half that were
prosecuted,
almost all of them,
yeah,
we're plea bargained down to bad
slaughter and the majority of them got a
conviction,
right.
It's three years,
50% of the time off for good behavior.
If you've behaved nicely,
you go to Jackson State Prison in
Michigan,
uh,
18 months later you're back out on the
streets of Detroit.
And Margo in particular was very
addressed.
The question of whether killing in these
contexts might either to actually
ultimately pay off.
For guys,
I tend to,
the view that actually killing is that,
oh,
he's overstepping the bounds of utility,
um,
that,
that deadly threats are very selfish,
rested and ineffectual,
but up again.
But that actually following through onto
this may be the,
you know,
the,
that nod functional tip of the iceberg,
but I honestly don't know that that's
true of these kinds of cases for them,
for exactly this reason that,
um,
guys get some social capital out of
having done it.
Well,
hypothetically,
will your mom,
the Unimog ammo there,
the tribe tribes in,
in South America and South America,
I believe are central,
I think it's south.
South America.
Yeah.
The more war,
like men have a much higher rep
production rate,
the ones who've killed more.
Now,
I don't know,
obviously it isn't necessarily the case
that that's directly translatable,
but there is some utility in being a
successful warrior.
It's,
that's actually one of the reasons that
I think that capitalism,
so to speak,
is underappreciated because in a very,
I'm speaking in a very specific sense is
that there are disagreeable and wore
like men and some of them are very
powerful in many ways,
not only physically but intellectually
in character logically and and with with
great ambition.
And the thing about capitalism is that
it enables them to wage war in a manner
that's,
that's not deadly and to become
successful that way and and to channel
they're there,
they're in intense competitive energy
into something that,
well I think often is often for a social
good.
Now it depends on how disagreeable the
person is and how selfish they are of
course.
But people like that also tend to get
punished in their,
in their cooperative interactions with
other people.
Yeah.
I mean I partly agree,
but I also feel that they offered toward
the social good is a bit hopeful.
I bead up to the degree that people are
successful at a fairly unrestrained
capitalist of competition.
It's usually at the expense of large
numbers of people at the bottom.
But it depends how unrestrained that
capitalist competition is.
I was thinking of social good as in
better than war.
Yeah.
Well better than war for sure.
For sure.
And sometimes,
and sometimes the way you succeed is by
producing goods that actually make
people's lives better.
Have no quarrel with that.
So now I also
wanted to ask you in the last couple of
chapters of your book,
you turned to what I would regard as
more political issues.
And so I,
I w and I am,
I'm very interested in inequality
because [inaudible] recapitulate for a
minute.
So your work and the work of other
people seems to indicate that as
inequality increases and dominance,
hierarchies get steeper.
Not only do young men get more violent
and so society becomes less stable,
but there's also detrimental impacts on
things like population health and,
and,
and that was,
that was documented quite nicely in the
spirit level.
And so I'm going to,
uh,
address a couple of criticisms of the
research and,
and then I want to ask you,
I want to have a discussion about your,
you're more prescriptive views,
if that's okay.
So,
so the first issue,
someone just emailed me this a while
back and when I was talking about
inequality and they said,
well,
what about places like China where the
rates of inequality are starting to
skyrocket quite substantially and have
been for,
you know,
several years,
maybe it'd be several decades,
yet the,
the homicide rate doesn't seem to be
budging much.
And so I thought,
well that was interesting.
Maybe there's something different about
East Asian communities,
so they tend to have very low crime
rates to begin with.
Uh,
like places like Japan for example,
have very low crime rates.
And so I'm wondering if what you think
about that,
is that a reasonable criticism and how
would you address it?
Fair enough.
Well,
I don't,
I don't think we could characterize,
you know,
orientals as less violent than box.
It had holes or anything like that.
I think history tells us otherwise that,
uh,
there's been a lot of severe and
dangerous violence in Japan,
in history,
and did China in history.
I don't know how good data we have on
Chinese homicide rates,
but what I've seen is that they have
been going up a bit lately,
but still the point that inequality has
been skyrocketing going to be partly
there's an interesting question about
time lags effect.
Some people,
you know,
how,
how sued is an increased inequality
effect going to play out as nasty
interpersonal behavior.
Um,
and you know,
people respond to inequality as a result
of their lifetime experiences.
You know,
you were talking about young kids,
I'll read very young children already
being predictable and the extent to
which they're willing to,
you know,
use violet tactics against other people
and that,
you know,
Asig three and four year olds could give
you some surprisingly good prediction of
how they'll behave as adults.
It's not inconceivable that the effects
of inequality even are influencing
people's development prenatally.
And so,
you know,
the uterus,
right?
Environments that they experience as a
function of,
of inequitable environments and the
stresses of fraught social comparisons
and so on that happened.
And those environments could be
influencing at all life stages.
So I don't think we have any strong
basis for expecting rapid changing
inequality to be a company to the short
term by rapid change of violence.
Of that said there,
you know,
it's certainly the case that there's
other things that matter and government
controls are wad.
I think,
I think strong governments that
monopolize the legitimate use of
violence can keep a lit of violence for
a long time.
Um,
I,
you know,
I would question whether they can keep
it played on it indefinitely,
but they could keep a lid on it for a
long time if you,
if you execute all
charged birders.
Um,
I presumed that that would keep the
incidents and birder doubt and not only
because those people could be
recidivists.
Great.
So,
so there's an element of potentially of
authoritarian control.
Yeah.
And then the other gentleman did,
I think is,
is particularly interesting is the time
lag argument.
I mean,
you don't know over what period of time
precisely inequality has it's pernicious
effects and maybe it's not even the span
of one lifetime.
It,
I do.
Do you have any data on that that that
would help help answer the question?
Well,
I did.
I did make reference in my book killing
the competition to one sociological
study that was looking at effects of
inequality.
Ud mortality generally at the notion
that inequality affects mortality
generally is mediated by what you were
talking about,
about health effects.
The idea that,
uh,
you know,
stresses of social comparisons produce
greater vulnerability to stress related
diseases and Admin,
fap,
many diseases,
most diseases maybe even are stress
related in their ultimate impacts on
people.
Um,
so there's this one sociological study
by a guy named Shag at Ohio state,
which sought effects of economic
inequality of mortality in general,
and came to the conclusion that there
the,
the effects were lag,
that the maximum impact on current
mortality was any quality seven years
ago,
which sounds kind of funny,
but he had analyses,
which seemed to show,
and I'm a bit wary about the legitimacy
of these analyses,
but they seem to me to show and they
seem to show to him that it equality of
a few years ago affects the chats that
you'll die now.
Um,
net of the effects of,
you know,
age and sex and
other predictors of mortality and that
there's sort of the Qbo and have
consequences of betty years of Mrj,
of,
of past inequality.
So seven years ago was the worst,
but six and eight also battered
additively five years ago and died years
ago also mattered additively 10 years
ago also mattered.
So that how bad inequality was in your
past seems to affect your likelihood of
dying.
Now the effects of violence have a,
have a look dead.
It's hard to figure out how you could
get a decent enough data set to do that,
right?
But I don't think it's impossible
health effects.
So I'm going to lay out an account of
the men.
You can tell me what you think about
this.
And all right,
so you're,
you're,
you're brain is always trying to
calculate to some degree how good things
are going for you.
And that's an extraordinarily difficult
calculation because life is uncertain
and ultimately uncertain and it's
difficult to predict the future except
perhaps by using the past as a marker.
And so what seems to happen is that our
nervous and our nervous systems are
always interested in how prepared we
should be for emergency at any given
moment.
And as far as I can tell there,
there are a number of ways that we
calibrate that.
One is baseline levels of trait
neuroticism,
so that sensitivity to anxiety and
uncertainty and emotional pain.
And so you seem to be born roughly
speaking at a,
at,
at an at your average level of
neuroticism,
which can vary substantially between
people.
It can be also adjusted at puberty and
then the environment can move you in one
direction or another.
So for example,
if you have a highly anxious child and
you encourage them to go out and
explore,
then you can move them towards the
normal range of Jerry Kagan has
demonstrated that quite nicely.
Okay.
So the first,
the first estimate of how worried you
should be about the future is like
genetic roll of the dice.
Some people will be born extraordinarily
worried,
roughly speaking,
and some people would be born hardly
worried at all.
And then that can be modified by the,
by the particulars of the social
environment.
Right.
So then the next thing it seems to me to
be part of the calculation is
comparison.
How well are you doing compared to
others?
That seems to be adjusted by mechanisms
that associate perceived social status
with Serotonin,
serotonergic activity such that as you
move up a dominance hierarchy,
you're,
your serotonin levels rise so that your
impulsivity,
which would be partly sensitive
sensitivity to immediate reward
declines.
And so does your sensitivity to negative
emotion.
Whereas if you plummet down to the
bottom of a hierarchy,
you start to become more reward seeking
and also more anxious.
And the reason for that more anxious and
is because the bottom of the dominance
hierarchy actually is a more dangerous
place to be because you don't have
access to,
don't have reliable access as reliable
to shelter or food or mating resources
or healthcare.
When you even see this in birds,
you know,
so if,
uh,
a flu sweeps through an avian
population,
it's the bedraggled birds at the bottom
of the dominance hierarchy to die first.
And so then one more thing and then,
then I tell me what you think about this
is that you have anything that seems to
happen is that as you plummet down the
dominance hierarchy and your mind
settles into a more depressed and
anxious state,
the levels of cortisol that you produce
chronically rise and cortisol is a good
hormone for activating you but in but
in,
but in high doses,
high continual doses,
it starts to produce brain damage,
particularly in the hippocampus and it
also suppresses immunological function
which makes you more susceptible to
infectious diseases.
So that seems to be approximately the
process and so it's no wonder that
people are trying to flee away from the
bottom up,
the dominance hierarchy.
Does that seem reasonable?
Yes.
Give me a,
give me a moment.
I've got a cough,
a blow by note.
Okay.
Hay fever season in southern Ontario.
Yeah.
I wish I were a better behavioral
endocrinologist and a do a bit more with
more expert in some of the processes
that you're talking about,
but a lot of that makes sense to be the
fraught social comparisons.
I mean,
the evidence certainly is that it's more
stressful to be low.
Right?
Can you bet a high rank Kagan,
we've had a little myth that all hot,
big,
a very high rank puts all this burden of
decision making.
He got you and that's terribly
stressful.
It makes you vulnerable to heart attack
and Blah Blah Blah.
And the day to say the opposite,
the data say that's not true.
The more power and status if you like
decision making authority,
you have the less vulnerable,
you seem to be distressed related
diseases.
So you know,
a lot of what you're saying makes,
makes evident sense to me.
Then the developmental story that you're
telling.
I mean I,
I,
I think it's right that people,
I don't,
I don't know how important the uh,
throw up the genetic diocese.
I think it's an extremely interesting
puzzle,
evolutionarily.
Why there's is much heritable genetic
variability in CBE.
Equally important domains as there is,
and I'm not convinced anybody has,
you know,
real really understands what bond you
weights,
how much variability there is.
But any case,
um,
that things are adjustable,
it responds to what you encounter.
And and a response to social status,
perceived social status of responses,
social comparisons makes evident sense
to me and again I,
I don't know enough about the putative
damaging affects of excessively
prolonged exposure to say high cortisol
levels to be sure whether there isn't
still sub adaptation sub actual
functionality to the response to long
term exposure lurking beneath the sea.
Big breakdown in the system because it
just seems to me that sort of a
Darwinian,
not evolutionary.
Um,
social scientists said psychiatrists and
psychologists have been too quick too
a soup pathology when they see states of
affairs that do a deed have damaging
consequences,
but they had subbed nevertheless have
some utility.
I,
I wish I do a little more about,
I think both the low serotonin and the
high cortisol levels are interesting in
that regard because what does happen is
the combination of those two things
makes you a more impulsive and be more
prepared for emergency action.
Both of those things are very useful in
an uncertain environment.
Detrimental.
The detrimental consequences seem to
occur as a consequence of prolonged
overload.
Is that because your body is utilizing,
imagine what your body is doing is
utilizing more units of resource per
moment of time because of the necessity
for preparation for unexpected events.
And that can become physiologically
exhausting in the long run.
So I think it,
it does,
it,
it seems to me that those biochemical
effects do underlie the sort of adaptive
responses that you described except that
you know,
too much is too much and if it's hard to
live at the bottom,
what that means is you age faster and
you don't live as long and you also have
higher susceptibility to disease.
And maybe in some sense that's the price
you pay for the adaptive impulsivity
that's also necessary to give you a
chance to shoot back up the hierarchy if
that's the sort of thing that you're
looking for.
Yeah,
no,
and I,
I can't help thinking about sort of the
evolutionary theories of,
uh,
of Senescence and bodily repair that,
or pioneer by Sir Peter Medawar back in
the 50s and develop more by George
Williams.
The idea that,
um,
betty,
betty things involve some sort of trade
off between expenditure for expenditure
of energy,
of accumulative resources,
of capacity in the pursuit of something
now at the expense of
reduced capacity to be successful later.
Um,
and so you know,
what breeze of why these chronic states
may have logged herb.
I'm a damaging effects is because
selection against big of these chronic
states has not been strong because those
who are in them for a long time didn't
historically tend to live very long
anyway.
And they're,
they're being,
if you like,
motivated or prepared to engage at a
high risk activities that at least have
subjects of short term payoff,
which is more or less what you said
actually.
Well,
and you know,
you talked about miss,
let's call it a misbegotten,
that there's stress at the top of the
dominance hierarchy,
just like there is stress at the bottom
and the stress at the top is
responsibility and decision making and
all of that.
And you know,
I,
I do believe that there's truth in that,
but there's an important,
another important biological element
that needs to be considered.
And so there's,
uh,
there's plenty of work done in the
domains of clinical psychology and some
of this is psychophysiological and neuro
physiological for that matter,
showing that a stress of an equivalent
magnitude as fewer negative effects if
it's taken on voluntarily.
So because what happens,
what happens is that if you voluntarily
engage in a stressful activity,
your approach systems are activated
rather than your defense systems.
And the approach systems are associated
with positive emotion and with,
and with much.
And where is the negative emotions are
associated with this defensive posturing
that includes preparation for emergency
and that's much more physiologically
damaging.
And so whether something,
whether you pick up a load voluntarily
or have it thrust upon you,
seems to make a big difference to how
heavy it is.
And that's,
that's very,
it's a very interesting piece of a set
of research studies as far as I'm
concerned.
It's quite fascinating that that can be
the case.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let me ask you another question.
Let's get down to,
we might say brass tacks here so we can
make a case that inequality destabilize
the societies and,
and,
and cranks up the male on male homicide
rate and the destabilization of curves
because young men become more and more
unpredictable and violent.
And so you could make a conservative
case as well as the liberal case for not
having a society that takes inequality
to an extreme because conservatives,
at least in principle,
should be concerned with the maintenance
of social stability over the long run.
So,
but,
okay.
And so then you might make a case for
income redistribution,
but that gets very,
very troublesome because it's not that
easy to redistribute income.
And that's what I want to talk to you
about.
So,
you know,
we're in a situation of course,
where the top 1% of the population,
uh,
controls a substantial proportion of the
economic resources and the top 1% of
that top 1% controls the bulk of that.
Now I've looked into that quite deeply
and that that distribution is,
it's not a normal distribution of money.
It's a perigo distribution of money.
But the weird thing about pareto
distributions,
and so that's a distribution where many,
many people end up with zero.
And you know,
just a few people end up with a lot is
that a prieto distribution characterizes
zero sum games that are played out to
their conclusion.
So like monopoly,
everybody starts in the middle,
but then random trading produces an
eventual prieto shaped distribution
where lots of people start to stack up
on the loser side.
One person accelerates towards victory
until finally everyone's at zero except
one person.
So it's the logical outcome of random
trading game.
So that's the first thing that's
interesting about the prieto
distribution.
The second thing that's interesting is
that pareto distributions,
um,
they prieto distributions emerge in
every domain of creative human
production,
not just the distribution of money.
So for example,
we did an analysis of the,
of creative achievement across the
lifespan using uh,
using,
uh,
an instrument called the creative
achievement questionnaire.
So what it did was assess people's
levels of competence across 13 potential
domains of creative activity.
And so we were looking at production
rather than creative thinking per se,
right?
Although those two things are related
and quite tightly,
we wanted to know who actually
accomplished things in the world.
And so for musical ability,
for example,
the zero score would be,
I have no training or,
or talent in this area.
And the maximum score would be,
you know,
my,
my comp,
my original compositions of being played
for international audiences.
And so we've now administered that to
hunt to hundreds of people.
And the median score is zero across all
13 domains.
It's a very,
very,
uh,
precise burrito distribution with a few
people who are the outliers producing
the overwhelming majority of the goods.
And you also,
and that there's a,
there's also a law that desota price,
uh,
came up with back in the 1960s governing
the output of scientific papers.
And he found that the square root of the
number of people operating within an
academic domain produced half the papers
that were published in that domain.
Right?
So,
you know,
so that's not so bad if there's 10
researchers because then three of them
are producing half the papers.
But if there's a thousand researchers
operating in a domain,
then 30 of them are producing half the
papers.
Okay,
so and then one more complication and
then I'm going to let you let you have
at this.
So I'd be looking for,
now you can think that the prio
distribution,
which by the way characterizes the
distribution of wealth in every known
society,
although the degree to which the
distribution is skewed differs.
You can say that the Prieto distribution
is a consequence of the,
of the final playing out of a random
trading game.
But then here's the complication.
This is something that's been bothering
me for years.
There are predictors of longterm life
success in relatively stable societies
and the best predictors are in this
order.
The first predictor is Iq,
the second predictor is trait
conscientiousness and it's about half as
powerful as Iq.
And the third predictor is low
neuroticism and it's about half as
powerful as conscientiousness.
So if you get a good measure of Iq and a
good measure of conscientiousness,
then you can predict about 25% of the
variance in performance,
especially across managerial,
administrative and academic domains.
And then with regards to entrepreneurial
performance,
you can use Iq and trade openness,
which is the creativity measure.
So there are powerful individual
differences that are driving
differential performance and also
driving this prieto distribution.
And so it's not merely a random game,
although how these people manage to make
it into not a random game is beyond me.
But there is evidence that,
that our society does hierarchically
arrange itself at least to some degree
by ability and competence.
And so then the question is how do you
factor that into the equation when
you're thinking about practical,
let's call them income.
I don't think it's so much income
redistribution is that it's an attempt
by society to stop too many people from
stacking up at zero and therefore
logically turning to violence and that
sort of thing as an alternative.
Well,
as well as an attempt to just
improve the level of justice in society.
The idea,
you know,
I mean,
especially if there's an element,
a strong element of randomness and who
ends up where then there's something
unjust about large numbers being stuck
down at the Xero.
But,
uh,
you know,
you say how is it possible to
redistribute,
but countries vary and the extent which
they do this,
they very into the extent to which they
tax inheritance,
they value barrier and the extent to
which they tax liar or cubs of they vary
and the extent to which they provide
education and health care try provide
relatively a universally trying to make
opportunity,
relatively universal.
They vary in these things and you know,
some of the happiest countries in the
world and I think the most productive
countries in the world,
um,
the Nordic countries,
Japan have the relatively equitable
because they rigged this gay board that
some other countries if you like.
Uh,
so you know,
you say that,
uh,
what stacks up at the top tend to be the
most competent creative people.
And to imply that to some degree we have
a meritocracy and to some degree we do
have a shock.
But you know,
the four wall Bollard Bard ehrs have as
much wealth as the hundred billion
poorest Americans putting together.
And they did nothing to earn it.
You could say,
well,
they're high quality people because they
got half of their genes from Sam Walton.
Did he did something.
Darn it.
Um,
that seems like a pretty weak argument
for why they should control that much.
Well,
if,
if inheritance were more severely taxed
in order to provide public goods for
everybody,
would this society to be worse off
would,
um,
flattening out that curve of
accomplished but actually reduced?
You know,
I think there's some,
there,
there's some evidence.
I wish I could pull it to the forefront
of my mind about the utility of
distributing grab buddy,
uh,
more or less equitably and certain
sciences,
the amount of science you get for your
buck is better.
Where you give lots of lots of people,
relatively small grants that will,
you give us a small number of people,
relatively large grades.
That's interesting because I've worked
in the grant system in the u s and
Canada and the grant system in the u s
is more of the,
give a few people a huge amount of money
for variety.
And in Canada it's distributed more
equitably.
And I must say that I vastly prefer the
Canadian system now.
Okay.
I agree with you and I think the
Canadian system has been moving
regrettably of the direction of the
American.
I mean,
it partly depends on the field of
science.
Of course,
if you need a buddy,
hey,
drug collider,
that you need billions,
millions of dollars if you're a
psychologist like you or be a thing to
seem to work better in many ways.
When you fund the higher proportion of
grads with a lower variance,
the amount awarded.
What I first came to mcmaster,
there was exactly,
oh no,
I shouldn't say what I first came by by
saying let's say the late eighties and
early nineties essentially everybody in
the department how to research grab from
either end circ that the natural
sciences and Engineering Research
Council of Canada or sure.
The social sciences and Humanities
Research Council of Canada,
usually the former at our particular
department,
everybody in the department had an
active research lab.
Everybody created the opportunity for
two or three students to do a bachelor's
thesis of their lab each year.
That would things get more variable.
People Start People's people who are
being productive,
who are getting out of scientific paper
or to doing decent work,
making a contribution to knowledge when
they start big to die.
These grads,
you know,
like you refuse to or three times of the
competition say,
well the hell with it.
You know,
I mean I've got tell you I've got a good
pinch of wind up.
I think I'll become a real estate
speculator.
The opportunities for
the dissemination of research
opportunity to a larger number of
students shrink.
Um,
I think it's,
it's been a disaster in surgery or I
guess,
you know,
an area where I was raised animal
behavior studies.
If you just look at either the number of
papers in top ranked journals by country
according to how they allocate their
funds or how much buddy is allocated to
it,
the buddy allocated to it as the less
strong predictor of you'd expect of the
equitability is a stronger predictor.
Sweet and Canada used to,
last time I looked both reg far above
the United States in numbers of papers
per capita getting into top quality
research gertels inedible behavior.
It's one little addict.
Don't know way,
but uh,
but I would be very,
if there's some
generality to this flowed well,
are there,
I wonder though,
um,
to play devil's advocate,
that's the thing about distributing
research funds more equitably is that
you are distributing them among a
population that's already being
extraordinarily highly selected for
capability.
And so it seems counterproductive
because it's for all the flaws of the
university system,
which are manifold.
It is still extraordinarily difficult to
become a professor.
It's a,
it's a multitiered selection system.
And so the people who do become
professors are on average,
very intelligent and on average,
very hardworking.
And we know that because we know what
the predictors are of success in
academia and its intelligence and
conscientiousness,
unsurprisingly,
although creativity seems to play almost
zero rule had that.
Well the thing,
yeah,
but that's partly because you know,
sciences and algorithmic gay,
right.
And just beating away at it busily is a
very,
very powerful mechanism.
So I'm not the least bit cynical about
that.
I mean the reason that science works is
because it's,
in some sense it has the aspect of
factory production.
It can be distributed.
Anyone can learn to do it and you get
along way is by nibbling at the edges.
You know,
it's continual,
continual slow progress when millions of
people are doing it is progress.
That's plenty rapid.
So,
okay,
so,
so there are definitely situations in
which denying people resources seems to
be completely counterproductive and that
would be one of them.
So
now the other question though is I would
say,
and also that's the thing,
there's also an effective means of
funneling resources to let's say a wide
range of professors.
It actually works the problem.
One of the problems with general income
redistribution is,
as far as I can tell,
is that we don't really know how to do
it very well.
And one of the,
I mean look here,
here's an example.
You can tell me what you think about
this.
So I used to work,
I used to live in northern Alberta when
the oil price,
sporadic oil,
oops were going on.
And my observation was that if you
wanted to make money in Alberta when an
oil boom was going on,
you didn't go out and work on the rigs.
Although if you did that,
you could make a tremendous amount of
money.
Now it was all young men who did that
pretty much say between the ages of 16
and 25,
something like that.
And they were making fantastic amounts
of money,
but they verged almost all of them came
out of it with nothing to show for it
because they would work for two weeks
and then go into town and it doesn't
have a blowout party for four days and
spent everything they got and expensive
cars and wreck them and so forth.
So it was reckless behavior.
Um,
that I think was a kid in some sense to
that,
to that,
uh,
to the,
to the steep dominance,
hierarchy,
violence and that sort of thing.
That for status seeking that you're
describing the people who really made
money where the bartenders,
right,
because they,
they,
they absorbed all the,
all the excess profits.
And actually generally,
generally speaking or comparatively
speaking,
we're able to utilize the money
properly.
Now,
the point I'm making is that an oil boom
isn't very effective way of distributing
wealth down the economic louder.
But it didn't necessarily seem to me to
be a very effective one because it
didn't because the money flowed back up
to the top 1% damn near as fast as you
can shovel it downwards.
And that's,
that's the thing about that damn prieto
distribution is that it's,
it seems there are people,
there's,
there's a,
there's a group,
there's a scientific subfield called
econo physicists and they actually,
they actually modeled the distribution
of money in an economy using the same
equations that model the distribution of
a gas into a vacuum.
So there's something that's natural law
like about this that the economists call
it the matthew principle,
right?
To those who have everything more will
be given and from those who have
nothing,
everything will be taken.
And I don't think that we've done a good
job of grappling with the actual
complexity of this and we tend to split
up into politically opposed,
uh,
what would you call camps and argue
about the,
the solution to inequality.
And the left wing solution is something
like,
you know,
distribute the money,
take it from the rich,
especially they undeserving rich.
If you can identify them and give it to
the poor and the conservatives say,
well no,
the poorest of the poor should bootstrap
themselves up and maybe be provided with
more opportunity and that might equalize
things.
But it isn't clear to me that we're
actually grappling with the magnitude of
the problem.
No,
it isn't clear
either.
But what you say about equalizing
opportunity for example,
is it a set to distributing the
resources because one way you equalize
opportunity is by having universal high
quality health care that's paid for by
sub sort of government.
Wherever you sub taxes picked up
somewhere.
Um,
free education,
universal access to education is
certainly another,
that's,
you know,
it's another way that an effect you
create a more egalitarian society.
So,
I mean there are,
there are certain domains,
certainly education and healthcare,
maybe some others that are not spraying
to mine.
Well I suppose the improvement of
various sorts of infra infrastructure
that,
you know,
make it easier to get from point a to
point b.
Um,
you know,
public,
publicly subsidized treads,
things like that can certainly be
contributors as well.
Now that's equalizing it.
It's all right.
You don't have to take anybody a give to
get specifically to anybody else.
Then there's things like a guaranteed
minimum,
a big cub at first.
It sounds like a crazy idea.
The idea that,
you know,
you should just,
we should take government accrued
resources which comes from some sort of
taxation and we should just make sure
everybody has 15,000 bucks a year to
start or something like that.
Um,
it sounds kind of wacky because they
standard argument against it from the
right has been that,
well underbite incentives and nobody
will produce all if you know,
if we could all be welfare rights,
well want to be welfare queens mostly.
And where this stuff has been tried by
understanding is that,
that it's been surprisingly successful
that there was an experiment better Toba
where a minimum big cub was tried for
awhile where,
Gosh,
yeah,
I remember that
[inaudible] about to try it.
Manatoba Toba has tried it.
It was an NDP government I think,
which them what replaced by conservative
or,
or nominally liberal governor,
but um,
then sort of cad the results.
But the results came to light later and
showed that for example,
the number of people who chose not to
work did not go up under this,
uh,
at that have various beneficial effects.
And I think rebates,
vc,
but I think even the idea of putting
buddy in the heads of everybody from the
great collective wealth that has
accumulated,
could be socially beneficial,
could be economically beneficial.
It could be environmentally beneficial.
Certainly the debates like education and
health care,
that's in effect a kind of
redistribution,
right?
That seems easy to effectuate.
I mean,
easy it not easy to effectuate in terms
of convincing people politically or,
or overcoming the propaganda against it.
But
we don't have a whole bunch of a,
obviously a whole bunch of of our wealth
is embodied in the infrastructure.
Yes.
Really noticed this for example,
when I lived in Montreal because
Montreal is a great city and one of the
things that distinguishes Montreal for
most cities that I've lived in,
uh,
especially western cities is that people
live in the city.
They don't live in their houses.
Yes.
And the fact that the city is
extraordinarily livable so you can walk
everywhere.
There's always something to do that's
exciting.
There's a tremendously active street
life means that there's access to
infrastructure and social capital
related wealth just distributed
everywhere.
And that's a lovely thing.
Um,
so I see cows,
I'm kind of looking for solutions to the
prieto distribution problem that
conservatives and liberals alike could
agree upon.
And so some of those you outlined
improve the infrastructure of our
society because those are public goods
that benefit everyone.
Then also improve productivity.
It seems to be no downside to that at
all.
Also raises employment,
improve the quality of education right
from right from day one,
which is something that I think we do a
very bad job of.
Um,
uh,
and then the issue with healthcare,
it's my understanding that the Canadian
healthcare system for it and it has
flaws,
um,
because it's of course dealing with an
impossible problem,
um,
still uses much less of its capital
on maintaining itself.
And for example,
um,
having to maintain an infrastructure
that collects money.
I know that the hospitals in the u s
spend something,
some substantial proportion of the
revenue,
I can't remember precisely,
but it's between 17 and 30%,
if I remember correctly.
Just gathering the money for their
services,
which seems to be rather counter
productive use of the [inaudible]
resources.
I wonder how much is spent on billboards
advertising their hospitals to drive the
interstate highways of the,
it's astonishing how much
information about,
you know,
cub to such and such where we have the
best cancer doctors that it isn't well
and the,
and Americans pay a lot for their
healthcare.
They do it easily.
Did they do indeed.
I spent three years there recently and
uh,
we paid a lot for healthcare coverage
that turned out not in fact to be held
up thorough a coverage.
Right.
Well,
when I lived in the states do,
and I have decent coverage,
I was teaching in Boston there I had a
pretty good program,
but it wasn't,
I wouldn't say it was
manifestly different from my Canadian
experience,
which has been mixed.
But of course it is very important to
note that hell that making people
healthy is impossible because everybody
gets sick and ages and dies.
And so it's an impossible task.
And it also indicates to me that that's
perhaps one of the reasons why it
doesn't fit so nicely into a free market
model because the free market assumes
that there's not infinite demand for
something and there is actually near
infinite demand for healthcare,
especially if they're dying.
There's that and there's also just,
you know,
it's,
it's an impossible problem because of
the aging population.
It's an impossible problem because you
know,
governments have one of the determinants
of the costs of the healthcare system is
held many empties.
You've got out there billing it and
governments have a tendency to one
respond to this by restricting the
number of new medics.
Um,
so as to restrict that a birth people
billing,
but this is not much of a solution but
you have large numbers of people try to
find a family doctor.
I just successfully,
okay so there is,
there is some meritocratic structure
sure.
To our society in so far as Iq
conscientiousness and openness predict
longterm life success.
And that's a good thing because that's
an indicator of of health and the
society.
I would say it's,
it's if your society is set up to,
to,
to allow people who are intelligent and
conscientious nearer the pinnacles of
power structures,
that's a good thing for everyone.
Now you could still have an argument
about how steep that gradient it should
be.
But then with regards to the,
to the guaranteed annual income issue,
I'm also concerned that the importance
of individual differences there are not
being considered.
So for example,
I don't know what people who are
extremely low in conscientiousness would
do with an annual income because they're
not inclined to work.
And it isn't obvious to me that
providing them with an easy way out is
the answer.
Because providing unconscientious people
with an easy way out seems to be
actually quite counterproductive.
And conscientiousness is a,
you know,
it's a decent predictor of longterm
success.
And we also don't know to what degree
necessity is a motivator,
which is of course the conservative
argument.
So,
so,
and we also don't know how homogenous
it's and small as society has to be
before income redistribution programs
will actually be successful.
It seems easier to implement them in
relatively homogenous societies like the
Scandinavian countries or the G or
Japan,
which is where they tend to have been
implemented with more success.
So that's a con complicated phenomena as
well.
And then the other thing that's really
going to come up on his heart in the
next 10 years,
I would say,
this is how it looks to me,
is that I think computational devices
are a multiplier of intelligence and
conscientiousness.
Because if you're smart and you know how
to use a computer and your diligence,
so as conscientious person would be,
then you're much more deadly than you
would be without your computer because
it multiplies your,
and there's a huge difference between
someone who really knows how to use a
computer,
including knowing how to program it.
The someone who's,
you know,
literate enough to use their ipad to,
to do a google search.
And so I think one of the things that's
also driving inequality,
particularly in societies like the
United States,
is that increasingly people who are
smart and conscientious can do a
tremendous amount of work without having
to hire anyone.
So we have these tiny companies that
employ almost no one that gathered
massive resources to themselves,
and that's going to be a problem.
Well,
here's a good example.
Here's one of the thing that's coming.
So,
you know,
the Tesla guys are working pretty hard
on autonomous vehicles and then make it
a lot of progress and they're not the
only one.
So obviously,
but you know,
the biggest employer for males in North
America is as driver.
I didn't.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's the biggest single employment
category.
So,
you know,
we're,
we're increasingly eradicating the
possibility for people who are on the
lower end of the intelligence
distribution and the lower end of the
conscientiousness distribution to find a
place in society.
And it's possible that providing them
with,
with minimal resources to survive might
be sufficient to solve that problem.
But I doubt it because as they say,
you know,
man does not live on bread alone.
And it seems to me that people need that
quest.
The degree to which people need to find
a productive and credible place in a
functional society is something that we
haven't yet.
We don't know the parameters of that.
They'll go,
I,
I don't disagree.
I mean,
the,
uh,
of course the loss of decently
paid work of and two dates,
they beige or computer revolution to
some extent,
or at least the,
uh,
you know,
modern electronic device and your phone
could do everything revolution.
And you know,
I live in Hamilton,
Ontario,
where were former whale watch bucket
taub with,
uh,
with an enormous number of people
working in decently paid,
working class jobs.
And those jobs,
but evaporating and pay.
If drivers evaporators work is going to
change work opportunities are going to
change.
And I take your point that people need
something that they can think of as
useful work.
Useful work.
You know,
it's interesting we're talking,
we're two males talking about this and
we're probably thinking from a sub what
bail perspective.
There's a lot of useful work that is
minimally or not at all comp compensated
than a predominantly female don't maids,
um,
daycare kinds of things,
various so called charitable activities
and so on.
And you know,
the,
the idea that people need something to
occupy their time with that feels
worthwhile.
That editors have been twist social
arena where they engage with other
people,
that they come home satisfied,
that they've done something useful and
they also,
you don't have a chicken in every pot
besides I need a work opportunities
shrink.
And if the next mark Zuckerberg kind of
play a hundred people to pull,
um,
tens of billions of dollars,
then where's that gonna come from?
Is,
it may come from various sorts of unpaid
work with a guaranteed cub that you
know,
enables that work to be paid and still
be fulfilling?
I don't know.
Well that's a good thing to think about.
I mean,
maybe,
maybe people will learn how to go out
into the community and spontaneously do
useful things.
Although I can tell you that my
experience trying to find gainful,
uh,
let's call it volunteer employments for
people who are on the lower end of the
ability distribution has been
absolutely,
uh,
it's,
it's difficult beyond imagination
because it turns out that finding a
volunteer position is actually no less
difficult.
And finding a job,
for example,
you have to go through a relatively
complicated process of police screening
for most jobs and you have to produce a
resume and you have to be able to work
in an office environment and you know,
you need to have all the abilities that
you would have if you were actually
having a real job.
And so that,
that makes things complicated as well.
So,
yeah.
No,
I want to come back also to what you
were saying about the predictive power
of Iq and conscientiousness,
which I don't dispute.
And I'm also not one of these people who
suffers that the delusion that these
things are totally open quotes,
socially determined,
close quotes.
I mean I understand and believe that
they have high heritability at
identifiable genetic sources in that
variability and so on.
But you know,
the standard old joke used to be,
you can tell me because you know more
about personality psychology that I do,
the standard old junk used to be that
everything's 50% heritable.
That uh,
that,
that pretty much anything that you could
measure as a trait that has any
stability within the lifetime also turns
out to have a heritability somewhere to
your 0.5.
But there's the other 0.5 of,
you know,
some people have low iqs because they
were exposed to two buck chuck
[inaudible].
Um,
you know,
um,
I believe that conscientiousness,
this can probably be,
um,
like I believe you suggested earlier
that we know something about this
already about developmental determinants
of swell,
of shifts in conscientiousness.
And,
uh,
so,
you know,
we have to caution ourselves against
talking about these individual
difference factors as if they are a
beautiful attributes of individuals that
are going to undermine any sort of
progressive improvement of,
of that just for people who are,
are,
are going to create bad byproducts of
attempts to produce social justice.
It's just going to,
you're going to leave here,
you're dumb and Kanchi it just people
out there being parasites or something.
Well,
you know,
um,
there,
there is of course decent evidence that
their socio cultural effects on Iq,
I mean the flynn effect,
which is named after the man who
described the,
the,
the phenomenon indicates that the
average Iq has been increasing quite
substantially over the last hundred
years.
And the reason for that,
no one knows for sure.
But one of the putative reasons for that
is that we've lifted the bottom out of
catastrophe.
So there aren't people whose iqs are
stunted by,
by exposure to zero information during
critical developmental periods and who
didn't get enough to eat.
Yeah.
Cause I was gonna say Superior Bell
Nutrition.
Everybody there a probation.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So we've,
we've wiped out in many ways,
we've wiped out the worst effects of
privation and that's increasingly true
as well.
On,
on the worldwide scale worldwide stage.
You know,
there's about 150,000 people a day right
now being lifted out of absolute poverty
by UN standards,
the fastest improvement in the history
of the world by a huge margin and also
about 300,000 people a day being hooked
up to the electrical grid.
So we are making some progress,
removing the absolute privation problem,
which is a nontrivial problem.
The problem with most of the attempts to
raise Iq is that they don't change the
variance in Iq.
They tend to raise the average Iq across
the population and that leaves the
inequality I Iq inequality problem,
basically untouched.
So there have been studies trying to
estimate how much socioeconomic,
um,
pressure,
let's say you have to place on an
individual to raise their iq lowering.
It's easy,
right?
Because making something worse is always
easier than making something better.
But if I remember correctly,
if you take a,
an identical twin who's adopted out at
birth in order to produce a 15 point
increase in Iq compared to the other
twin,
which is a one standard deviation
increase and about the same as the
average difference between a university
student in,
in an average state college and an
average high school student,
you have to move the one twin from the
fifth percentile of socioeconomic status
to the 95th percentile.
So you need about a three standard
deviation improvement and socioeconomic
conditions to produce a one standard
deviation improvement in Iq.
So it looks like it can be done,
but it's,
but it's expensive,
you know,
and
I see,
I see what you're saying.
I'm kind of surprised
actually.
I mean,
given,
you know,
we just mentioned bell nutrition as one
possible source of low Iq one possible
developmental source.
I'm kind of surprised that,
uh,
to the degree that the flynn effect
might be due to things like,
or reduction of the number of people
exposed to severe malnutrition,
that wouldn't have also simultaneously
truncated the variance a little bit.
Um,
that seems like they said,
sorry,
let me restate that.
It has truncated,
it has truncated the variance,
although the data on that isn't clear
isn't as clear.
So,
but,
but I,
I do believe that it's a reasonable
inference to make that the variance has
been truncated.
It's also hidden to some degree because
the Iq tests are always renew warm to
keep the variance set of standard 15
points.
Yeah.
So,
so it makes it difficult to look
retrospectively and see what's happened
to the variance.
So,
but,
uh,
the other problem too is that,
you know,
you get these stories now and then about
these companies that come out with the
claims that their brain exercises can
improve Iq in the literature on that is
damn dismal.
I can tell you it's that the holy grail
is to produce cognitive exercises that
produce a legitimate impact on fluid
intelligence.
And like,
there has been a lot of work down on
that.
And the answer is so far is that it
doesn't work.
So what about the game?
What about the video gaming?
I mean,
I know there has been a suggestion that
playing video games actually improves at
least sub aspects of intelligence.
There's a couple of studies that
indicated that video games might improve
spatial intelligence,
but
problem,
and I think this is,
this is a critical problem or apps,
an insoluble one or at least no one's
solved it,
is that what you get is that if you,
if you exercise yourself substantially
on a given game,
you can radically accelerate your
performance in the game.
So you can get much better at those
specific skill share.
But you don't get generalization across
cognitive sets,
which is what really hoping for because
I thought,
I thought that was the claim from
somebody.
They have shown some increases in
spatial Iq,
but there's not very many studies.
And I would say they're far over
balanced by the other side of the
research equation,
which continually says,
and I've looked at this because I'm
really interested in the improvement of
Iq.
I mean that's,
that's the holy grail in some sense.
And that,
and,
uh,
the,
the overwhelming preponderance of
evidence suggests that you don't get
generalization outside the narrow
domain.
Now why that is,
and even this,
it's even worse,
hey,
because you might say,
well,
imagine that you could take five
different domains of intelligence still
associated type with the g and you had
people practice routines in all five
dimensions.
Maybe you'd get generalization under
those circumstances.
And the,
the,
the results of the research attempting
that indicate that no,
as soon as you move away from those
specific practice instances,
you don't get generalization.
So,
I mean,
I guess it's,
I guess the subways,
some of this is to be expected from the
consideration that everything is an
allocation problem with it within the
body at Brae in,
uh,
um,
that,
you know,
by a large,
an approvement blood domain tends to be
bought at the expense of something else.
Yeah,
just that.
Right.
And then conscientiousness,
I can tell you some research we've done.
That's cool.
Although we haven't been able to
demonstrate that it's actually improved
conscientiousness,
the first thing to note about
conscientiousness is that no one
understands it at all.
Especially the industriousness element.
There's no plausible biological,
psychological neurophysiological or
animal models for conscientiousness.
All we've got is self reports.
We can't even find tasks that
conscientious people do better.
It's unbelievable.
But I'm self reports really.
Also freeport,
well you can get reports from teachers
and parents and so forth,
but it's all human report.
Okay.
The only way we can measure it,
and we know like in my lab we probably
tried 200 tasks trying to find something
that conscientiousness,
conscientious people do better.
No luck.
We can derive it from linguistic
analysis of verbal output now to some
degree.
But that's still,
that's not a task,
you know.
Yeah.
So now we,
we produced a series of programs called
the self authoring suite and one of
them,
the future authoring program to writing
program that helps people lay out their
plans for the future in,
in detail.
So they have to consider their,
um,
their intimate relationships,
their career goals,
their educational goals,
their use of time outside work,
their plans to maintain mental and
physical health,
their use of drugs and alcohol.
They have to write for 15 minutes about
what kind of life they'd like to have if
they were taking care of themselves
three to five years in the future.
And then to write for the same amount of
time,
how terrible their life could be if all
their bad habits took control.
And then they have to turn the positive
vision into an implementable plan.
And we've managed to improve their
college grades by about 20% and drop out
there,
drop,
drop their dropout rate by about 25%
over about 10,000 students now.
But you know,
we tried to see if that was mediated by
an improvement and conscientiousness and
there was no evidence for that.
What it was mediated by was number of
words written during the exercise.
So it turns out that thinking more about
your future helps,
the more you think about it,
the more it helps.
And maybe that,
you know,
maybe that would translate into an
improvement in conscientiousness across
time.
But,
um,
there haven't been any credible studies
that I know of indicating that there are
exercises that can be done to improve
conscientiousness.
So that's also,
you know,
troublesome and worrisome because that
would be a nice thing to be able to do.
Yeah.
I mean I haven't thought much about it.
They don't know much about the
literature on conscientiousness as a
trait,
but the word seems to connote to me as
an ordinary English speaker has a strong
social element to it as well.
It's kind of like a conscientious person
is somebody who doesn't forget his
obligations.
Um,
your index of conscientiousness and a
university professor is,
you know,
somebody has asked you to write them a
reference letter for getting into
graduate school or whatever.
Do you actually prioritize getting the
DAB thing done?
I'd Tibor is there some risks that
you'll just forget about it and shove it
to them somewhere else?
I imagine cut,
she had just,
this is having a strong element of
attentiveness to social obligation and
to the wellbeing of others as it is
defined and the personality of the
literature doesn't have any of that.
Well,
I would,
I would say not so much attention to the
wellbeing of others because that's more
trait agreeableness,
that's more than maternal dimension.
But there's definitely a massive effect
of social obligation,
which is part of the reason why
conservatives tend to be hired
conscientiousness than liberals,
but it's not well being of others.
It's duty.
And so the,
the,
the conscientious types may form and
maintain social contracts.
Yes,
they implement their plans and they seem
to feel shame and self contempt when
they,
when they fail to live up to their
social obligations.
And so that's another thing that's
interesting about the income
redistribution idea because it's
conceivable to me that conscientious
people would hate that because
conscientious people do very badly,
for example,
if they're,
um,
if they're laid off from work,
even if it's not their fault,
they still take themselves apart for
their failure.
So,
and so conscientious people in
particular seem to find inactivity
without productivity,
highly aversive and adverse,
if enough to really cause them,
you know,
major health problems.
So well,
could,
that brings us back to what we were
discussing a little while ago.
The problem of
ensuring that large numbers people have
access to bd goofball work in an age at
which it is more and more the case that
uh,
that big components of the economy are
blue bag away with very few employees.
I that's going to continue.
That's probably going to escalate
or back to that same topic to some
extent.
Yes.
But again,
I,
I mean I think,
I think any inequality of opportunity is
sort of they bought of our bedrock of
any quality.
Yeah.
Having its impact upon us.
It's,
it's,
it's certainly the bond but bedrock of,
of why we should care about it.
Odd,
moral and social justice grouts it's
like,
well why should people who,
okay,
why should bloods birthright affect the
opportunity is available to what and
well,
it's also a social catastrophe because
hypothetically you want to set up a
society so that whatever someone has to
offer is maximally offerable to the
community because otherwise the
community loses.
Yes.
Now,
it seems to be,
I mean,
I think one of the great examples of
that,
although I don't think this accounts for
all of it,
is that the relationship between the
provision of women's rights by countries
and their economic productivity is
staggeringly high.
So I think that also has to do with o
openness in general to transformation
and change with,
with,
with the provision of women's rights
being an index of that.
But nonetheless,
it's a great predictor of eventual
economic success.
Well,
so our park,
we get a ducks and partly perhaps bar
more direct effect that after all it
slightly over half the population,
um,
maybe their talents are better utilized.
Right.
Well that's certainly what we would
hope.
And I think,
I think as you said,
I think the evidence at least suggests
that.
Yeah.
So,
okay,
so let me recapitulate because we should
probably fold this up.
It's so,
so as far as I'm concerned,
your work was revolutionary because it
undermined the general proposition that
the fundamental cause of crime and
violent crime in particular was poverty.
Instead you,
you flipped it,
you flipped it on edge,
so to speak.
And made the,
made the claim well substantiated by the
research that it's relative poverty that
drives violent crime because of status
seeking primarily among young men and
older.
There are effects of absolute privation
and that would be the poverty.
It's the,
the effects of relative deprivation of
status are much more,
let's say,
especially in our societies,
much more socially significant.
Yes.
And up the status competition is driven
at least in part by the desire of men to
attain status,
to obtain access to,
to women roughly speaking.
And it's partly because women outsourced
the problem of mate selection to the
male competition domain.
Right.
So the males compete,
the women peel off the top.
It's like a market solution in some
sense.
And then,
and then having pointed out that
inequality not only drives male homicide
but also tends to destabilize societies.
There is an impetus for people to
consider how we can stop the winner from
taking all without becoming unduly or
authoritarian about it or,
or,
or impeding individual productivity.
Given the fact that there is individual
variation in yes,
in the elements that actually produce
productivity.
That's our set of social problems,
exacerbated by the fact that we're going
to be wiping out employment for huge
categories,
particularly of men over the next 15
years.
Yeah.
Let me,
uh,
in this context,
just make a point that I spent most of a
chapter of my book on and that is that
the notion that inequality is somehow,
um,
the engine of productivity.
It's been pretty much rejected by
economists themselves in recent years.
I've come to the conclusion that
relatively equitable places actually
have more of economic productivity in
the ensuing period of time than those
that start out boring,
inequitable.
And there's a lot of reasons for that.
Um,
the one that I think is most striking to
you that I would commend people to look
into is the concept of useless,
if you like,
are wasteful expenditure on guard wave
or relatively on equal societies.
A guard waiver is a term coined by
economists samples and Arjun Jayadev.
And what they've shown is that the
number of people who are employed just
jobs like being security guards,
um,
goes up as it equality goes up.
It's no great surprise when you think
about it,
but you could defy guard labor bar
broadly or more narrowly.
And the general result is that a large
proportion of people are engaged at work
then is it a sense nod productive?
It's just trying to prevent people from
usurping the property of other people
and that this is a very wasteful
consequences of extreme inequality and
economic waste that's reduced to
relatively equitable societies.
And there are others.
As the
society becomes more unequal,
it tilts towards authoritarianism at
multiple levels.
Organization,
it's one that just,
sorry,
I was just going to say add towards
exactly this and it's counterproductive
even from the point of view of,
of simple,
you know,
economic criteria,
GDP,
it so odd that,
uh,
that inequality gets in the way that for
a bunch of reasons and other really
interesting when the ball's has,
um,
has articulated it in a book.
Paul's b o w l e s sat bowls to people I
don't look about.
Um,
I think that's book was called the new
politics of any quality of
redistribution to that.
I liked it a lot.
Anyway.
One thing that he's shown that I thought
was very interesting and it never
entered my head before I read was that
the actual quality of goods it is
society can be damaged by severity,
quality.
When
rich individuals,
which firms have the capacity to keep
innovators and small companies from
establishing themselves.
You mentioned before about the
differences and entrepreneurial
undertakings and where large numbers of
people with worthy small business plans
can't capitalize them properly.
It can't get off the ground.
You've actually got a phenomenon of
people with lots of wealth and shoddy
products can drive people with better
quality products who are trying to get
started at the bottom out of the bar
camp with negative results for just the
consumer.
Well,
the society having people stack up at
zero zero turns out to be a very,
very difficult place to get out of
because you can't leverage yourself out
of it.
And what's also in those really unequal
societies to like say Central American
societies,
it's also becomes increasingly
unpleasant for the people who are
wealthy because they're only wealthy in
a very narrowly defined way because they
can't go outside.
They can't let their children go out on
into public because they'll get
kidnapped.
I mean,
the societies get pretty ugly when the
fences have to be really high and yes,
and,
and so,
so
yeah.
Wow.
So the rich countries,
rich countries of the world,
those problems are not absent.
I mean there are certainly worse than
the u s than they are in Canada or most
of western Europe.
Yeah.
Well,
all right.
That was really good.
I'm very happy that you agreed to do a
podcast with Ben and I mean,
I found your work well.
I'm,
I definitely regard you as one of the
people who's been highly influential on
my thinking.
I mean,
I think that work on relative poverty is
just,
and the effect sizes,
the work you guys did in Chicago,
your work on indicating the adaptive
utility of,
of uncertainty related dominous
challenges in,
in unequal societies.
All of that's brilliant I think can
nicely biologically predicated in the
science has done extremely soundly and
it has remarkable policy implications
and you know,
and it changes the view around crime
and,
and wealth and in a very important way
to tilt it over towards the inequality
side.
I think it's,
and it fits so nicely in with the
dominance hierarchy,
literature and all of that.
It's,
it's really profound stuff as far as I'm
concerned.
So I'm really glad you had a chance to
share it with everyone.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate those kind words.
You can,
flattery will get you everywhere.
Yeah.
Well the thing is,
the best kind of flattery is truth.
So,
and uh,
I would certainly recommend that people
take a look at your book if they're
interested in what we've been
discussing.
Again,
that's killing the competition,
which is,
it's very readable,
I would say.
It provides a lovely argument with
regards to inequality,
addresses the major criticisms,
I think very effectively and,
and starts to lay out what is going to
be an increasingly necessary public
discussion about how civilized societies
can,
can ensure that they don't collapse into
two extreme distribution,
um,
uh,
w into two extreme distributions of
wealth or other resources.
It's a real danger.
It's a conscious,
unconscious,
constant danger.
It needs to be thought through and
addressed very intelligently.
So thanks again.
Hopefully,
maybe we'll get another chance to talk,
hopefully a couple of hundred thousand
people to watch this.
That will be good.
That'll okay.
Great.
Thanks a lot.
You Bet.
[inaudible] signing off.
Okay.